freestyle rap is right made up on the
spot based entirely on suggestions it's
not written it's not prepared it's not
rehearsed it is improvised and therefore
you uh
oh quit because because will was saying
it so that's okay well that's a good
topic uh i i take five usually and i'm
going to say that the rest of them can't
be too obvious you can't say things that
have come up in the show you can't say
food or animals because they're too
common let's get the middle of the room
what would you like a rap about
oh there were several those dudes what
did you say
baby hey one second you're not the
person i'm pointing at are you
you said the spanish flu yeah the uk
cool then you said
baby archie that's megan and harry's
baby right yeah he's not really a babe
anymore he goes a bit is he like like
yeah i guess he's small um
okay so quit the spanish flu
sorry sorry
you say baby
shark it's this yeah i know but it's not
like 2016. you can come up with really
good stuff it doesn't have to be
soft-serve [ __ ] you don't have to be
like i'll save football because you can
probably rhyme that
[Music]
that's a blast from the past i love it
county 2012 baby archie
creeps and the spanish flu and what was
that ray rice
gay rights what are you saying
[Applause]
oh so what what was this name because i
it's definitely not a football player
called gay rights
[Music]
find out some someone else is saying
something about a girlfriend an elevator
so this does he beat up his girlfriend
but he was a nice guy
they're still together to this day
okay well that's going to be an
interesting part of the wrap great i'm
glad we pushed past
baby shark to end up with ray rice the
man who beat up his girlfriend in in the
lift
yes
and
this is a freestyle like i said made up
on the spot base and all that stuff we
may drop that beat now good sir and then
let's have a little bit of fun
and
a little bit more volume on the beat for
me when there's bass and drums kick is
it's going to be nice cool
a century passing corona pandemic what
we in 200 years ago back spanish flu
influenza told me to offend you if you
hadn't found that died maybe get the
family tree look inside my old brain
aunt mabel wasn't able to survive she
died perished at the dinner table
influenza coming from overseas the
spaniards they were like ccc we're
trying to infect you hurts like ouchie
in the spanish flu did we even have a
fouchy equivalent i don't know it's
abusing if i had the news i would rattle
through and soothe things out like a zoo
like i found the truth 2012 10 years ago
you were shouting out maybe had a
t-shirt you know me a warlord in africa
the name connie
[Applause]
that's a hot job i can give some little
facts that i told you if i was commonly
have an army of soldiers all under eight
they walk with the rifles if you try and
[ __ ] with me if you try and try for that
i run for pop you from afar warlord
africa big cigar he would sit down on
his throne what's he doing now not
inside no guantanamo how well he just
kind of went off our map but now he's
brought back put the freestyle rap he's
like the new trend maybe we get him on
twitter and if he wants a new army
that's more little well yeah you know
the guy that he's getting he just sends
a dm to harry and megan and says hello
there you know me back in the day a
decade ago connie i want a new guy for
my army have you got a small ginger kid
that like archie
where are you between you get the head
shot there you can brain falls and baby
archie he's kind of mean why because he
would go and assassinate the queen like
yo lizzy you really gotta face this you
weren't really mean to my mama you were
racist and let me tell you this i'll go
so far you killed princess diana that's
my grandma
there's some gas in it i don't mean the
air bag that's inside there of the car
in 97 i mean in the vagina little air
pocket you're like please stop it i'm
[Music]
it comes out over there i'm like no
please go walk away maybe issue the
breeze from your undercarriage it won't
end the marriage the only thing that
would if i gave a face of barrage of my
fists i was like yeah so hard to resist
come me ray rice and your lady in the
lift go into the top floor who wants
more he was like yeah i'm gonna clock
jaws knock you down and they're still
together that's kind of weird your rain
rise it's not clever to do it on the
tape but it's hard to resist was the
fight in an elevator no it's in a lift
[Applause]
you